[Music]
so I am indeed Allen pike and I work at
steam clock software all the way in
Vancouver Canada and what we get excited
about is building delightful apps that's
what we do that's that's what we're
passionate about that's what gets us up
in the morning and although we often do
that using native technology on iOS
Android and generally mobile platforms
we also really love javascript we use it
on the server we want to use it as much
as we can in our apps and so that's why
today we're gonna embed a JavaScript
runtime it's gonna be a lot of fun
and we're gonna do that so that we can
embrace our platforms enable tinkering
render native OpenGL mix javascript and
native code and share javascript in
between native apps so that sounds fun
right let's do it
so the motivation behind this all of why
are we even looking at native technology
is to build delightful apps um so what
do I mean when I say that I I mean not
just apps that work that do what they
need to do but apps that are really cool
apps that are delightful that have a
fascinating UI that performs extremely
well beautiful touch interactions
they're fun they're quirky and that get
people excited and say how'd they even
do that or how do they even think of
that UI it's just so so great to use and
so that's what gets us really exciting
is is blowing people's minds and often
that means that we need to reach into
our our native UI toolkits or OpenGL or
some of these other technologies to do
that but we still want to use JavaScript
as much as possible so we're gonna embed
a JavaScript runtime it's gonna be a lot
of fun and it's really easy all you need
to do is get cloned v8 so that's pretty
easy and then you just check out the
build steps I go through that a few
hours later you have v8 built on your
machine it's really awesome
and then you're gonna consult the v8 and
betters guide which has a lot of really
handy information for example note the
handle stack is not part of the C++ call
stack but the handle scopes are embedded
in the C++ stack handle scopes can only
be stack allocated not allocated with
new
you know what on second thought let's
not do that I'm gonna tell you a story
instead so sometime ago maybe four or
five months ago steam club we were
browsing through the WebKit repo as you
do and we were looking at what would be
involved to embed javascriptcore into
our apps and Nigel Brooke he came across
something really interesting a series of
commits and these commits started on New
Year's Eve everyone else is out partying
drinking get getting crazy and some
Apple engineers were getting crazy as
well but they were getting crazy adding
something very interesting to
javascriptcore an objective-c API so
Daniel finds this and he soars like hey
cool look at this and like oh my god we
have to write about this we have to
build stuff on this we gotta like you
know we got to pull this out and so we
did we wrote about it and we shared sort
of a hello world project on github and a
lot of you thought that was really cool
and gave us some great feedback on it
and we're really excited this finding
this thing in the wit could repo though
didn't answer the questions though that
we had the really big question which is
why are they doing this what is this for
is this something that's going to ship
in one of the operating systems and if
it is which one well thankfully just a
few weeks later maybe about a month
later came WWDC and with WWDC came a
giant NDA it was great
of course it was this is the IO six NDA
the Iowa seven NDA looks like that so
it's a little bit different
the effect is the same though which is
the Apple doesn't want as publicizing
stuff about beta api's which might
change or might go away entirely which I
totally understand thankfully for all of
you Jay s confi you comes at the exact
right time because on Tuesday Apple
announced iOS 7 they released it its GM
it's done and all the api's are final um
so I can actually now confide in you
that on Iowa 7 as well as Mac OS 10.9
there's a new API it's a public API
called JavaScript core framework and
that's built right into the operating
system it's public is maintained by
Apple and it's an objective-c to
JavaScript bridge hey cool a free
JavaScript bridge so so what does that
was exactly mean like what does a
JavaScript bridge look like well ideally
a JavaScript bridge lets JavaScript be
JavaScript right on your JavaScript will
still you know if they've done their job
right your JavaScript will still look
like the JavaScript you would normally
write except that you can interface with
native code um so let's take a look at
some examples what does that what does
that look like so we've got a JavaScript
function here JavaScript really great at
math so we want to help objective-c code
do math with JavaScript because it's
just so great at it
so we define a multiply function and it
looks just like a multiply function it's
what you would expect it's cool so so
that's cool and now that we've defined
that an objective-c we can go evaluate
that script so we just think all J's
context I've instantiated one here I
evaluate the script and then I can reach
in to that JavaScript context and pull
out the multiply function once you have
a handle on an injective C you can call
it I'm using this call with arguments
thing if you're not familiar with
Objective C syntax this crazy like
basket of at signs and square brackets
in in the bottom right corner is passing
arguments into into this JavaScript
function so what I'm defining here is
native Objective C number types they get
passed over to JavaScript and JavaScript
can work with them as numbers just as
they would expect and then when returns
back to Objective C we can get that
value out if you have a script and we
can cast it too
integer or whatever so our
statically-typed and our JavaScript
world they work well together so that's
great I hope to have a script looks like
JavaScript what happens if we go the
other direction so let's take a look at
that same multiply function and
Objective C it's beautiful so I don't
know maybe that's why we're writing
JavaScript instead of a check to see if
we can this is actually the the block
syntax injective C for defining the
exact same thing that we did in
JavaScript and you get used to that and
it makes sense
it's just takes two integers multiplies
them returns it it's great so we define
our multiply function in objective-c and
then in exactly like we did in the last
example we can reach into the JavaScript
context and then we can actually we can
just say okay hey I have to find this
thing called multiply you have it and
now you can work with it so in
JavaScript it looks like as simple as it
could possibly be
we just have multiply and and when we
call that multiply we pass it into one
and two they get cast two inside the
directive seaside we got a
multiplication back and I'm in
JavaScript so that's pretty cool right
like you know we got we got JavaScript
check to see going back and and for a
one-line or multiply obviously that's
not gonna like you know shake the world
or change anything fundamentally but it
sort of gives you an idea of what this
API can do so how do we do it what's
what is the API well there's three main
classes that you care about if you care
about this API and the big one is j/s
context it's basically loads of
JavaScript p.m. and you can throw a
javascript files into it and it's what
we're using to reach in and take
objects-- out of the JavaScript runtime
at the JavaScript context into the
objective-c world and putting them back
so this is kind of your workhorse class
um but then there's two helper classes
that allow us to go in each direction
there's something called JSX port which
is a protocol a protocol as objective-c
ism that basically is an annotation so
you can say hey this this particular
this particular objective-c class I want
it to be bridged over the JavaScript
side and so it's really easy to do that
for your own classes it's basically
trivial there's a little bit of
boilerplate if you want to j/s export an
existing objective-c class that you
don't have
you don't have the source for but you
can write a script that will automate
that and that's something that we're
planning to do ourselves so so chase
export and then going in the other
direction we have jeaious value and so
J's value is a object for encapsulating
a JavaScript value in the objective-c
world because of course like we can't
have these like crazy type list things
in an objective-c we need to make sure
that we know exactly what's going on
with them so Jase value lets us hold on
to JavaScript types and cast them to
various things so so that's all very
cool well what is that what does that
bring us you know so we've got all these
things put together what is the equation
here we got javascriptcore right
and we've had JavaScript Cora mobile for
a long time it's part of mobile safari
but now we can instantiate it without a
webview I'm using public API so we don't
have to actually go through that build
your own a package your own so that's
cool we don't have the the memory
overhead or or the startup overhead of
starting webview and we also get this
nice bridging functionality which is
cool so that's that's what we get that
we like there's something that we get
that we don't really wouldn't have
really missed if we didn't have it and
then Society of reference cycles so
objective-c is not garbage collected
it's a reference counting language and
the compiler automatically counts
references for you and it cleans up
memory when nothing is pointing to it
but the the key is that it only cleans
up memory when nothing is pointing to it
so you could have like a two objects
that point to each other and if the rest
of the object graph doesn't point to it
then the the runtime is not going to
know that that's a reference cycle and
it needs to be garbage collected um so
that's something we don't normally have
to deal with in JavaScript and so if
you're not familiar with working with
Jeff to C and you're sort of
experimenting with this I recommend you
check out the WWC video from this this
past June on how to avoid it's generally
on this JavaScript stuff but the kind of
gold in there is avoiding reference
cycles so that's kind of annoying
but what do we get in return we get this
more flexibility right and we get all
these new new things that are easier and
and we can do stuff like instantiate
multiple JavaScript context and having
them having them run on different
threads really easily
and we actually suspect that it may be
possible to instantiate a JavaScript
context have the JavaScript get parsed
and then write that out to disk and then
restore it later for faster startup
times I'm something we want to
experiment with and this is the kind of
stuff that like you try to do that with
a webview like oh god helped you so I
mean maybe it's possible I don't know
but all this stuff comes together to
make for some delightful possibilities
there's stuff that that we're not
exactly sure I mean this thing like i io
seven coming out basically now right so
we don't exactly know all the things
that are gonna shake out of this but
there's definitely some really cool
possibilities so what kind of
possibilities one this dear to my heart
is embracing our platforms and when I
say that I mean you know the different
mobile platforms that our users are
using and they're the ones are you
they're using for particularly scens
right and as web developers especially
when we're building like in a webview we
tend not to we sort of pave over the
differences in between each platform
right partly just cuz it's a pain in the
butt to to make your your web app feel
like the the local operating system and
so for example like maybe we did all
this work to make our iOS 6 app look
it's like a web app but it looks like
iOS 6 and then iOS 7 comes out and kicks
us in the nuts and it's like ok
everything's completely different right
like and and sometimes it's not even
that that hard to do right like iOS 7 we
got these white backgrounds type heavy
layouts focus on images flat rectangles
blue text you can click is really high
tech stuff right you know or it's the
web from 1997 right it's it's not like
we can't make these things happen in
webview there are things that are hard
though right like it has these physics
based gestures and it's beautiful 3d
effects we got this 60 frames a second
scrolling on all these various places
while doing a real-time blur operation
on mobile on like an iPhone like for for
s-class hardware and highly responsive
touch you know all these cool things and
so it's it's kind of you know
controversial like oh yeah you can't
make yeah you can do some of these
things on mobile it's possible or you
can you get great performance are you
gonna build a delightful app probably
not maybe not at least not yet
so so so what is that
what does that mean that's our ios7 so
that means that if we build with a
native UI or at least as much as makes
sense for any given app then we can have
these native looking and feeling things
that will conform to what the users want
and what they expect on any given
platform but still potentially write a
lot of our code in JavaScript
titanium obviously has been barking up
this tree for a long time and
Appcelerator guys and I think a lot of
us have played with titanium I've played
with it before and I find it can be
pretty heavy
I've been quoted as calling titanium a
500-pound monolith of eclipse and
licensing which is kind of mean because
technically it is not 500 pounds it's
211 megabytes but these guys are really
smart and they understand this problem
and when they saw the the new stuff that
Apple was doing at WWDC their minds were
blown and they promptly actually
embarked on a complete rewrite of
titanium to take advantage of this
approach um they're actually going to
JavaScript core on every platform
porting it to Android and 4 to
JavaScript core to Windows as well and
they're also building something called
Hyperloop which is a compiler from
JavaScript into native code on each
platform
um so they're going totally crazy with
this like JavaScript bridge stuff and
then you know you're writing something
is because titanium like how long is it
gonna take I don't know however how many
months or years but it's definitely
worth keeping an eye on what they're up
to
if you're interested in this stuff
because there's a lot of cool there's a
lot of cool thinking and prototyping
going on there at the Appcelerator so we
general want to enable tinkering right
and native apps historically not that
easy for people who are not coders or
not really up on necessarily you have
senior level people to like tinker
around and just play with your
objective-c or your C or your your your
native app and this is something that
you know other industries have been
doing for a long time right like if any
of you are familiar with the games
industry you know about Lua
right Louis this little embeddable
language that most games nowadays have
some sort of scripting facility for a
or first levels or various things that
they are not necessarily performance
critical to the app but they are their
wrists so they're written in Lua so
they're easier to tie with and you know
level designers can edit the Lua
without having to build this giant C++
project well we can do the exactly the
same thing but with the JavaScript right
because Java scripts incredibly
performant dynamic language and it we
get this bridge for free and we can also
embed the JavaScript runtime in games
and anything else that we want to so
that's a really interesting way to
enable tinkering but when I think about
enabling tinkering the story that always
comes to mind is the story of this this
is the Mac calculator from the original
Macintosh it was up there it looked
exactly like this all the way until Mac
OS 9 so like for 15 years and the way
this calculator came about it didn't
originally look like this there's an
engineer at Apple whose employee number
eight at the time but he was still like
he was like a high when he was fourteen
or something like that and in the
development of the Macintosh in 1982 um
he wanted to do this calculator to show
off the new drawing code that the
Macintosh was going to ship with so he
hacked something together didn't look
like this and he showed it to Steve Jobs
it seems like this is like these
fonts are wrong this pattern is wrong
that the buttons are too big like I
changed everything so Chris goes and he
changes everything I an exit he shows it
to Steve and seems like oh this is
this is wrong the fonts wrong blah blah
blah you know potentially even
contradicting things he told them to
yesterday so after a couple iterations
of this Chris gets wise and realizes
that he's not he shouldn't be building
what Steve asked him to build he should
instead be building the Steve Jobs
calculator construction construction
toolkit so that's what he built um so
this is this beautiful application his
purpose was to let Steve tinker with all
these various values and and the shadows
and fonts and outlines and stuff like
that and and he did in ten minutes later
they had the calculator that we just saw
that shipped for like 15 years
um so I thought what better demo for
something for technology that makes it
easier to tinker with applications than
a calculator so I'm gonna show you the
calculator
so this is the iOS simulator this is
nothing because I'm not mirroring pardon
command f1 cool I'm totally gonna press
that it does nothing unless I suck at
pressing command f1 but my understanding
of oh it's it's command brightness down
not kind of fun okay cool so this is the
iOS simulator and I'm gonna make it a
little bigger for you guys and it's the
a so this is the iOS simulator and this
is Iowa 7 and ok cool a calculator right
you guys have never seen a calculator
before so I'm gonna show you kind of how
it works
58 wow that's really cool and so we can
do all the sort of things we can like a
store thinks in memory and clear them
and restore them so that's a cool little
demo app that you guys can check out on
github and see how we've built this but
this front-end is entirely native UI
right if we take a look this is build an
interface builder there's no JavaScript
code that's assembling the UI it's
entirely done in insert our native tools
in Xcode so all when you know Iowa's new
versions come out we get all this sort
of new functionality and stuff that we
get in the developer tools but we still
have this thing running here in in
JavaScript and all of the logic is
written in JavaScript
um so you may be skeptical that the
logic is running in JavaScript so I
should probably prove it to you
javascript is pretty good at math so
let's let's take a look so let's see
what this equals yeah yeah
that's that's right and javascript
interprets numbers starting with a zero
as octal because that's pretty cool so
let's see what this equals yeah cool
okay yeah so it's JavaScript um so we've
married the power of objective-c with
the math power of JavaScript and created
something pretty amazing I think you're
all going to want to check it out um
okay so that's fine let's undo my
fullscreen anything cool a calculator
awesome so you can check this out on
github we put that live now steam clock
/gs calc and I'll post the slides
obviously after the talk and that's
really cool really impressive you can do
a calculator you know it's more
impressive though is rendering native
OpenGL so it's kind of opposite ends of
the holy crap
spectrum and when people hear OpenGL
they tend to sink games but there's
actually a lot of really great uses for
OpenGL
for rendering non game applications this
is something we built recently steam
cloth called the map the Internet
it's 3d you can you can interact with it
you can zoom through time and see the
history of the internet you can do an
interactive trace route it was actually
Angelina that that wrote the the
traceroute that goes through the
internet in 3d and so it's this crazy 3d
application and we've built it with C++
and OpenGL on each platform but there's
no reason to the logic that is non
performance intensive needed to be
written in C++ and we realized that now
and if we were to do it today we would
probably try this JavaScript bridge
stuff we're not the first people to
think of embedding javascript in an
OpenGL app though um there's this thing
called ejecta that you guys may have
seen and it's related to the impact
project so dynamic Domenic Zebrowski who
wrote bio lab disasters like the first
html5 html5 games that was actually like
really worth playing he's built this
thing that's actually a native
implementation of canvas audio and WebGL
that you can
deploy to to iOS and run all of your
existing like sort of WebGL game that
runs in the browser you can run it run
it on iOS and you know this is possible
in like a webview well not good WebGL
but the performance implications of this
are that it runs way faster and with
substantially even more dramatically
with a lot less memory overhead and so
you're still using the same open
technologies is it using the same season
the same API is WebGL and all that kind
of stuff but with the native back-end
and you know obviously we don't have
WebGL in the webview on iOS yet anyway
so it's a nice sort of polyfill so so in
general there's all sorts of cool ways
we can mix javascript in native right so
for example you know we steam clock we
tend to build apps this way right we
have node on the server which is great
obviously we want to have script there
and then we'll end up building a native
sort of logic layer and a UI layer and
then a native logic layer and UI layer
in each platform ok well that works fine
but it's we're writing Java and then
you're writing Java right so let's not
do that let's write the logic layer in
JavaScript right so we got the the
models and controllers in JavaScript and
the UI layer for the views in native
code and that's great if your your UI is
the intensive part of your application
but what if your UI is really simple if
some enterprise app but you're doing
some you know intensive number crunching
or video or something like that maybe we
do it the other way around right we use
web views we use HTML on the front end
and then we have a native layer for our
models and controllers right
or maybe we build something like a
Cordova webview or we use Cordova
Cordova webview so most of you are
familiar with PhoneGap Apache Cordova
and well they have a component where you
can drop Cordova into your application
so it's sort of side by side you can
have your native UI code your native
models and controllers and then you can
also have your your web technology or
your webview
model some trellis in JavaScript and so
my point is that however you mix these
technologies if they're the right
solution for your app then they're the
right solution right like even if this
is the right solution for your app right
that's probably not the right solution
for your app I would not recommend that
particular architecture but the point is
that there's lots of opportunities for
sharing JavaScript and we want to share
with JavaScript in our in our native
apps so of course we built this demo I'm
showing showing the the calculator on
iOS but we will be totally remiss if we
didn't get running on Android right
thankfully there's something on there's
a JavaScript runtime called Rhino which
must be probably been heard of it's been
around for a while but it's it's written
in Java so it's extremely easy to embed
on Android so I'm just gonna quickly
show that to prove to you guys that I
need to do my little dance again so I'm
gonna show you guys this thing running
in android yeah an Android okay so this
is acting éclairs uses the exact same
JavaScript but is again built with a
native UI and so just in case you guys
are still skeptical of my claims let's
type 16 9s one two three four five six
seven eight nine 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
and see what that's equal to right 10 20
liyan yeah okay slow clap okay great so
this this is still an ongoing you can
try that out on both platforms what's
the point of all of this what's what's
the takeaway I've shown all these
different offices you know demos and
ways that we can use JavaScript we can
mix Drive script I just want to
encourage you to try embedding a
JavaScript runtime whether you go
through the VA instructions whether you
use the iOS 7 API is you embed Rhino you
and bread javascriptcore try it out so
with that I encourage you to go out and
go build the life laps
you